you
okay let's get this start again real
talk style where it's the script this
week minecraft and Dwarf Fortress nerd
damn straight
alright but these aren't narrative yeah
I know but that's kind of why I wanted
to take a look at them we've spent a lot
of time talking about narrative and
meaning so what happens when we look at
something that doesn't have a structured
narrative at all Skyrim has an extremely
malleable narrative that lets you drift
from plot thread to plot thread but
there's not a whole lot for you to do
without getting caught in some kind of
scripted story hell you can't even run
down the road for more than five minutes
before some random chump runs up to you
and an z request so what happens to
narrative in the absence of structure
you know we could have just used
Koyaanisqatsi as the example true but
Koyaanisqatsi is still a fixed
experience every time you watch it the
movies going to be the same
I mean sure you'll come up with
different meanings based on you know
things you've experienced since the last
time you saw it or your mood at the time
but the movie itself isn't fundamentally
going to change okay I see what you're
getting at I don't think it's going to
go quite the way you want it to but
let's give it a shot
minecraft and Dwarf Fortress are a pair
of computer games that can best be
described as creativity games similar to
Lego actually you know what scratch that
Lego isn't the best comparison they are
really more like sand castles you're
probably thinking wait what's the
difference between Legos and sand
castles they're both just sitting around
building crap and to that I would say
correct but short-sighted I'll explain
the distinction in a bit the core
difference between the two games comes
from depth and perspective one is
first-person while the other is
third-person one has an engaging
crafting system while the other
simulates entire industries and one has
an iconic world with a blank slate
history well the other generates world
histories that make the works of Tolkien
look like shoddy outline for a D&D
campaign okay there's a lot of
differences when you get down to the
nitty-gritty but the bottom line is that
minecraft is accessible and a ton of fun
while Dwarf Fortress is deeper than the
Mariana Trench and a ton of fun
why we're talking about them together
isn't because the difference is though
it's because of the similarities both
are ultimately games about taking a
randomly generated environment and
creating something out of it it's a
pretty straightforward setup but how
does that turn into a story of any kind
we've got a protagonist in a setting but
where's the antagonist where is the
conflict well the conflict comes from
something called a chaos generator which
is exactly what it sounds like it makes
chaos in Minecraft there's always a
creeper just itching to blow your house
up while in Dwarf Fortress there's well
let's put it this way the game's
tutorial ends with the line losing is
fun this is why I said sand castles not
Legos see when you're playing with LEGOs
you're sitting inside with a pile of
inventory two bricks when you build a
sandcastle you're on the beach and have
to work around the random nature of the
beach itself traffic from other people
and the tide waiting to inevitably crush
everything you've carefully built but
you know what that's okay because Dwarf
Fortress is right losing is fun or it
can be if there's a narrative message to
take from these games that would be it
everything breaks everything falls apart
everything eventually ends but that's
okay
you can throw a hissy fit or you can
start over rebuild it and maybe make it
better this time is from this lack of
structure this lack of scripting this
noise and chaos that stories emerge
special stories that involve a layer of
investment that scripted narratives
can't quite replicate it's one thing to
watch a film about the downfall of a
civilization or the rise of a hero it's
another to see barren landscape
transformed into a cozy bustling village
through your own effort or sit helpless
as a kingdom you've called from bare
stone devolves into civil war like this
one time I'm playing dwarf fortress and
over the course of a couple years of
game time the neighboring goblin Kingdom
sent wave after wave seized against me
eventually breaching my outer defenses
and while the rest of my military hidden
the basement crying into their beer one
lone axe maiden stood against all comers
racking up 32 confirmed kills before
losing her right arm she still managed
to kill three more invaders with her
shield alone then a giant toad got in a
lucky strike and broke her neck opening
the way for the remaining invaders to
swarm before
honestly the rest of the dwarves have
what was coming to them after that
stupid pansies couldn't even get out
their background you want to know what a
real hero looks like that's a real hero
blood and honor hold the line nerd